[Música]
com vocês
rolando lá em wimbledon do nenê
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muito obrigado sábado ó que coisa bonita
que coisa maravilhosa
obrigado tava pra vocês muito obrigado
estou muito feliz de estar aqui hoje eu
vim fazer esse show pra vocês
a primeira viagem que eu fiz eu fui pra
são paulo e comecei a viajar para mais
tá pra fora do nordeste né
nos shows uma coisa que eu percebi o
pessoal de fora do nordeste ele tem um
preconceito com a gente e o [ __ ] é isso
porque porque eles pensam que aqui no
nordeste só tem sol e calor é só sol e
calor só de ônibus ou do piauí
flávia maria meu deus do céu aberto
parece que eu trouxe o sol no bolso para
jogar nele eu não entendo uma eu não
posso sentir calor em são paulo não
quero não posso eu fizer assim o cara
que foi eu estou com calor e tem 800
calor do nordeste não eu digo todo o
nordeste não sou filho de satanás não
para o povo não é o serra
tem que ser sofrido
ele não acredita que é do piauí cara tem
que ser queimado do sol sofrido de
buscar água meio dia com um balde na
cabeça
meus oito irmãos nutrido
o janes ouviu sovando são tudo tudo com
o som para ficar mais pobre né não
acredita que a troca de ônibus do piauí
não parece não é porque não quer muito
branquinho
na minha casa tem telha né pronto tá bom
eu não tem gente a perna você já viu a
onça é de onde eu sou do piauí aip chave
uma onça de quer dizer que se eu for
japão jogou pouco no meio da rua
amor de deus no fim do ano
é [ __ ] ea gente é diferente a gente é
diferente dos demais
a gente é muito diferente o pessoal fala
as pessoas o amam a gente dizendo que
tem a cabeça branca
eu não achei um defeito isso é uma
qualidade a gente é fofo a gente parece
aqueles cachorros e bota em cima da
televisão bat racinha bonitinho
acho bonito e eu acho que a gente é
diferente das outras pessoas não é como
o pessoal de fora o pessoal de fora
totalmente diferente da gente a gente é
é a outra coisa por nós é [ __ ] mas é
tanta coisa pode prestar atenção é não
gripe a só depois de pegar a menina
não mais sério a gente é porque se você
parar prestar atenção a gente de toda a
situação a gente faz um carnaval cara
não é como o pessoal de são paulo
exemplo são paulo passou harry potter
harry potter o menino da magia do outro
lado da rua passou a nossa meu irmão
harry potter em nossas mãos em arian foi
embora harry potter não é só meu irmão
não sabem nossa parte 3 foi passou no
piauí ea memória harry potter mas o do
outro lado da rua acaba de me afastar a
fazer mais por transforma essa para são
paulo o robô
aí pega pelo braço para mostrar à mãe
por um irmão pra todo mundo
a gente gosta peido amariam perder um é
um carnaval não é como em são paulo são
paulo exemplo belo horizonte né
aqui seis pessoas um peido o primeiro
que sentido faz aquilo pra gente sair
ele sai saiu saiu ontem saiu onde sai o
outro fica só que perdoa porque quem
pega no abandono pedro onde fiquei
curtindo um pouquinho a brisa e deu
trabalho a fazer chegar essa [ __ ] né
não
agora pegue o piauí é o primeiro que
sente é um escândalo vai ver nem fedeu
só fez isso só fez um barulho e do
cálculo a área vinha passando alguém
fala sério pela mordida no passo por
aqui não vê por aqui é porque estão
cagando aqui minha senhora pelo amor de
deus a gente faz um csi peido vai
encontrar o cara que perdoa que
palmilhar ele a cpi não estava entre a
comenda ouro rússia em bolsa
a jogar isso fora o jeito ea gente é
criativo
a gente passa 15 minutos no chão
esperando para perguntar o que é fácil
quem está procurando as pregas e oculta
por aqui o do jô
a gente tem isso aí a gente é diferente
era engraçado engraçado um vento que sai
do culto nada é muito massa né
eu vou falar uma coisa para vocês agora
não é piada
é sério isso é sério eu estava em casa
assistindo à sessão da tarde sentado
eu peguei eu juro pra vocês que falou
maicon marcou juro juro estava de boa
sentado tranquilo na minha gente a gente
sabe quando perde é bom resultado ao
produto do núcleo de dança que adormeceu
e se é bom é o de levantar dia na perna
para não agredir muito sofá né
no que eu levantei lipóico
[Aplausos]
é disse perrô de cuca no show mico
eles falam pedro fala em 1 pelo feeling
que fala marca de carro temos filme faz
xixi tudo bem
podre esse é o pior do mundo
harvey e mar e rapaz a atenção que
quando alguém pede a gente fica com ódio
a pessoa perde a gente começa a falar no
gt cebola em um mundo tão raiva sob um
ódio rancor na gente mas quando a gente
pega aí é grafado
a rede ipê das pessoas começa a ser
bowie mundo você o pt do b em sair perde
microsom apple do filme
então você fica com ódio quando alguém
pedro só tem uma pessoa que pereira e
você não fica com ódio
mamãe mamãe pedra recheia calado só
porque tem um e vem com um negócio
chamado superioridade é o seguinte eu
sou sua mãe a sua boca e falando então
quando a manteiga e é todo o pedro de
uma mãe é a coisa mais podre que eu já
vi na minha vida porque o nosso pé de
novo né
um pedido de 15 anos ver o que vem
coxinha coca cola o peido a senhora de
45 anos mas que em 45 anos de ódio na
gente chegar de 18 horas a uma mãe pelo
amor de deus
foi assim que nasceu a conjuntivite
mãe você não pode falar nada só que a
gente não é burro não a gente dá um
indício que sentiu a tensão mãe pede que
ela faça kiyota sua mãe aqui tem ninguém
em casa você 2 ó mandaqui
você está aqui senti o cheiro mamãe só
que ela mais esperto que a gente sabe é
que ela faz
ela faz de conta que nada aconteceu
pode prestar atenção ela sabe por que é
que você está chamando ela porque o
ambiente está inabitável
mas não passa um gato pertas perto dessa
mulher
de tão podre que está o cara faz aqui ó
como em a bela forma mãe ela faça isso
aqui o que foi bem quer ver essa mulher
virar o cão diga-se mães era pai do
rapaz eu digo não é só tem eu ea senhora
me respeitasse o valor da multa
ela fala com tanta verdade que eu
acredito que foi o mesmo
chega gente em kaká tinha essa foi a
idéia eu assumo a gente assume pela mãe
me perdoa mãe agora um amigo a gente não
perdeu não só a vocês são a minha casa
tem mais ninguém se sente o cheiro pegou
na filha aparelho que só tem você 2
o cara faz aqui ó eu e meu amigo só tem
eu e você aqui
outro pai do meu computador mente cantor
sentindo só que o amigo de verdade não
consegue esconder não consegue esconder
o pensar porque sorriso
o coelho tem uma conexão bluetooth com a
boca
a pessoa perde a vontade de sorrir à
venda na hora cada
e se você pressionar você consegue saber
quem perdoou
foi tudo feito ele fala não foi eu que
estou falando sério
sai pelo 8
tenho raiva de pedro e óleo dp ele spiro
espirro tenho raiva porque tem gente que
você não pode falar
quando a pessoa vai espirrar porque
corta o estilo dela e ela sanga então
você tem que esperar ela espirrar
só que pra mim a coisa mais ridícula do
mundo é esperar uma pessoa determinada e
espirrar para falar pode prestar atenção
à pessoa com este ano está pagando
energia do universo ela feliz você fala
assim e vamos à vila de ti e você fica
assim ó
ai passou o download
eu tenho raiva raiva disse à rádio
catalunha tem muito mais raiva porque
meu nariz é grande e eu acho o seminário
está suja toda hora
então o que é que eu faço eu toda hora
de empanar isso e quando vem alguma
coisa
o catarro ele tem que ser mais estudado
pela ciência porque tem uma cola que não
é de deus não ama você tira a irem pra
cá né
aí você faz assim ela pega neste ano
você faz assim ela para passar 15
minutos driblando caparro eu não sai
cara passa no pé fala desgraça vai
tomanocu quando é para mão qual cabo
ele volta ao poder dá pra fazer um filme
o retorno do carro ganhou só queria uma
técnica
eu crio uma técnica muito boa pois nunca
mais acontecer
eu faço o seguinte eu sou muito feio mas
o dedo no nariz que eu vou limpar ou
espremendo do crânio aqui primeiro
experimento incremento chega na barata o
que tiver na beirada o fora meus amigos
ficam reclamando senai também ficou
dentro da lei não é para limpar e de
quanto valem para o cultivo do coco é da
beirada
então pronto nunca vi ninguém está
fazendo que é também pânico é depois a
escuta assim o não tem
eu nunca vi alguém fazer isso
tenho raiva de sair tão rápido tapa na
cara dos outros também
agora mesmo fiquei nervoso quando eu
entrar aqui escondeu a vontade de
cagayan não quis ficar aqui e aqui na
minha casa eu fico naquela que é difícil
dar se a prestar atenção que quando
chega na casa do outro a bota é amiga
ela não quer ir embora ela fica ali com
você
canadá 8 descarga 88 e descarga
nada pode perder a atenção será onde
está a granada do arnado três descargas
nada 43 cada
ela está na mesma posição que ela fala
aquela posição de quem está descansando
né adversidades carga no défice ea bocha
tipo assim descansando tabela
ela não vai embora a cara da nova
descarga vai para r 3 segundo ela oi eu
toco - o porquê não desce
embora não pois volta entra no ódio
coisa ruim
eu sei lá tem casais aqui tem até gente
favor de muitos casais têm aqui na
frente o casalzinho ali rapaz ali também
o casal né meu nome de preto como
vanderson né daqui médio
anda sul não da mulher vanessa foi falar
com a boca como fernanda haia fernando
vanderson e tecladista levando um de som
de i a fotos edelvandro encostado em um
teclado a paisagem nada veio aqui atrai
contracapa fernando assim eu tomava
banho enquanto tentava junto com o ano e
11 anos que sofrem o ano coisa móvel um
ano no canadá já trocou de absorvente na
casa dele pode falar só os amigos aqui
passar em quase ninguém lê
nunca mas quando troca desse momento
deixa aberto ou fechado pode falar a
verdade fechada né passei cópia dele
para camuflar para isso é muito bom isso
é muito bom
isso é um ano um ano passar muito tempo
ela vai estar com essas cuidadosa cidade
toda não
um dia vai deixar um absorvente aberto
vai e isso vai ter que estar preparado
quando não é cor de deus onde eu cheguei
em casa fico eu não estava preparado
para aquilo anos antes quando eu lembro
do cheiro que eu vi aquela chacina
eu usei aquele tanto de sangue do meu
deus do céu namorada fraturou o
periquito meu deus faturou quebrou eu
não sei se ela foi dar um pulo e rasgou
a ver não está logado levans eu digo
aqui morreu morreu é a alma
eu dormi nutella passou campeã na minha
frente eu digo deus é fiel juiz soltou
um thank sair de si não morreu é um ex
gay e chamou o que é isso aqui é exceção
e talvez não fazer uma campanha de
doação de funk ela disse pra quem o
distrato deixou todinho aqui o amor
recebe que habitualmente é diferente do
que acontece quando eu fui perguntar
porque não sabia que tinha diferenças e
absorvente ea mulher vanessa quando ela
sabe que tu não entende do assunto no
que dá uma aula do assunto
ela gosta de chamar gente de burro
ela estava de costas para o ver a
ganância disse sim amor tem diferença se
você é tão burro existe absorvente
coladas em aba tem até absorvente que o
cheiro de rosas do campo
eu disse pra quê meu deus que quando o
bota não ficou cheio de roda do campo
a rosa do campo morre no nosso mais uma
rosa nesse caso não há dolo pois hoje eu
vou bater robin e eu sem saber o que era
um hobby que é uma b e ela foi me
explicado uma b também é um absorvente
só que é um pouco diferente
como é que eu posso te dizer vou te dar
um exemplo o exemplo que ela me deu né
sabe uma pia onde sua filha de sua amp
an
quanto é que a água da pia não passe
pelo buraco na pia o que é que tu faz o
diga o campo lá no buraco da p
ela disse também que vai ajudar ela é
manso por bacana ela foi lá botar o bebê
que tinha saído botou tudo a gente foi
um jantar romântico no top proparoxítona
jantares em massa né
e eu peguei o macarrão botei na boca né
por legal
ok eu acho que ela foi botar o carro
rápido demais na boca que uma pontinha
do gasto pegou no céu da boca do sertão
e tira só que ele corin tranqüilo de boa
romântico né top box e falei pô vou dar
um beijo nela jc romântico não leva até
à vista avançou o sangue escorrendo eu
digo meu deus do céu ap encheu a bóia
derramar tira
[Aplausos]
eu sei lá meu irmão a mulher perturbado
a petição cara mulheres só a mulher vai
responder sim ou não você namoraria um
cara que tirou a barba
daqui só tem aqui na metade da cara
porque a mulher tinha os cabelos da
perna daqui só tem aqui no joelho e não
pode pegar na canela não que elas andam
botou a mão ela sai atrás ela escutou
quem não gostava porque corta só metade
não que eu gosto de passar o l'oréal
aipa praia de biquíni e fica aqui pra cá
pra lá do que pra cá o goku sai adins
cabelo vovó era louca para minha avó era
louca com 95 anos e andar de bicicleta
a senhora é doida wanda se você parar
para prestar atenção o velho quanto mais
velho fica a velha quanto mais velha ela
fica mais grosso ela fala eo velho
quanto mais velho e ele fica mais fina e
fala com athael volta fazendo o que
estou cuidando bem menor que seu vôo
deve ficar a concha curtir a pagar
porque é o melhor desde o início o velho
é desse jeito totalmente diferente e vou
querer andar de bicicleta volta do ano
de bicicleta o vôo chegou de bicicleta e
saiu empurrando deu dois minutos voltou
empurrando a um pneu tenha torto assim
um olho roxo
faltando perdendo na chapa da rep de voz
era caiu era meu filho meu pet rolando o
pedal aqui
pedalei para desenrolar o outro pt-ro
luto
eu digo bota no bolso ou pelo amor de
densa do alô vai surda agora muito dura
muito
agora muito surdo e meu avô era duas
vezes mais surdo que minha avó
ele morava sozinho no império tem
aqueles interior que cada casa dois
quilômetros na outra ele só conversavam
entre eles era cada conversa linda que
eu via uma vez cheguei pensando nessa
conversa eu cheguei lá em casa meu voto
a minha vó eu voltava lá e não voltava
em cima da casa tirando o roteiro
mexendo nas telhas tira logo teria
fiquei embaixo daquela coisa de menino
aí eu vou lá em cima e chegou meu voto
nada ou a conversa tá tirando goteira
disse não tô tirando goteira ela desaba
o pessoal estava tirando goteira e saiu
e foi embora
eu queria saber o que eles escutaram do
outro
a resposta foi uma certeza é todo mundo
louco lá em casa meu pai é louco cada um
seu nome é o márcio mas o meu pai acorda
muito cedo muito cedo e pai ele tem um
problema o pai no geral é um problema
que quando ele acorda ele quer que a
casa corre toda com ele e você pergunta
pra que ele fala palavra tapas e não
quer fazer nada
a corda que ora massa gorda 86 hora o
meu deus do céu
márcio quando meu pai acorda o homem que
apresenta o globo rural ea escova os
dentes mas não tem quem aguente não para
vender mamãe é louca minha mãe é louca
minha mãe ou de quem tem tatuagem eu sou
pintada de tatuagem aparece a escola de
uma bancada de escola pública toda
riscada desprevenido os rolos
todo riscado eu sou eu fui fazer a
primeira tatuagem no meio de toalhas
cheguei a mãe tem um momento na vida do
adolescente que ele acha que ele manda
em casa eu cheguei em casa diz mãe eu
vou fazer uma tatuagem ela disse você
não é mais meu filho e eu disse mas só
tatuar diziam eles não meu filho a
desculpa que ela deus meu filho quem tem
tatuagem bate na mãe eu disse meu deus
do céu como é que deve tamanho da amc
gamer nega
todo dia 8 cacetada galera
a mãe é louca eu falei vou fazer essa
tatuagens mãe santa atuar disse não foi
bem pequenininho e não mas jesus não
enquanto você morar embaixo do meu tempo
ela fala isso que a gente não tem para
onde ir ela fala enquanto você morar
embaixo do meu teto você não pode atuar
só que eu saí de casa com 16 anos eu não
moro mais em baixo da tabela
só que um dia ia voltar no dia eu vou
estar na minha casa eu vejo então estava
num dilema
eu vou dizer eu vou esconder
meus irmãos ninguém esconde nada de mãe
nada tá na bíblia isso
vanderson cabelo 3 a 5 4 não escondem
nada de mãe
você pode fazer uma tatuagem na roda ela
do curso era baixa para pegar o chinelo
a mim quer dar a quem ela tem um erro
bobo uma merda é boa pois a bola no
verão baleia fica assim ó ailton é tonta
nã eu digo vou fazer essa merda ela vai
descobrir a brigar comigo eu quem é
bandido malandros comungado refere josé
rozo não sei que eu digo não fazer isso
só que eu morava 800 km da minha mãe eu
em teresina em goiás onde eu já sei como
fazer eu vou ligar pra minha mãe antes
de fazer a tatuagem dizendo que eu já
fiz a tatuagem para ver o que ela vai
dizer se ela brigar muito eu não faço
se ela brigar só um pouquinho obrigada
eu sabia né eu liguei pra ela falou 'mãe
eu quero tocar que destina dinheiro não
nasce depois fala eu fiz a tatuagem
mãe de um minuto nada dois minutos sem
falar nada três minutos sem falar nada e
eu preocupado coração tudo tudo isso ana
que quatro minutos sem falar nada seis
minutos sem falar nada
55 minutos sem falar nada de tim para
claro alegação de ter noção da minha
agonia no momento está preocupada com
ela na hora com o bônus está acabando e
eu mamãe aí foi que ela falou que foi
meu filho com as drogas
mãe é mãe de brinks incluindo a mãe é
louca cara e muita calma e assistir
televisão em pé
a mãe faz assim
sim só faz ninguém
você pega ela para sentar ela sangra
falta lhe bater mãe sempre ao site
televisão ligada e vou desligar
eu diria que parece que houve um pedra
na cabeça dela eu desligava quem foi
foi essa a china está estudando o outro
lado da casa de tirar a audição da minha
volta eu vou votar nela é um ela pode
está no japão para no japão derrubou com
todas as avós vem do japão quem nada do
nada não sabe quanto é que custa deve
ser mesmo no controle vejo televisão vou
saber maluco doido louca amigos e só
pode levar para sua casa sabe que sua
mãe conhece
geralmente ela conhece três abatem 5.000
amiga ela conhece 3
geralmente nem você nem amigo dessas
pessoas que conhecem sabe o nome sabe
que é o pai que a mãe sabia que mora
fora esses três amigos qualquer um pois
eleva na sua casa ela recebe com
desconfiança
tão grande mãe está aqui meu amigo
barack obama
tudo bomba é que está pronto um brinco
no bom eu não diga nada
ela é por sumir por uns 15 segundos na
farsa vergonha aqui ela vai ficar assim
o índice vem cá pobres ii no centro não
pegue água não fala na 15 meninos
um amigo meu engraçado que não conhecia
seguindo eu tenho pra mim que era
envolvida com troca eu tenho pra mim o
que merda é eu tenho pra mim que se você
tem já é seu já é duas coisas que me
fala que eu nunca vou entender um é eu
tenho pra mim ea outra quando ela vai
contar um sonho que ela teve de noite
ela disse que alguém disse não é eu faço
muitos eu sonhei e disse que estava com
a faca que disse não disse que eu
cheguei no caso de quem disse o narrador
não só da senhora já disse é louca
elas são doida cara tem uma frase que
não sai da boca da sua mãe que essa aqui
ó é ser menino dia vamos enlouquecer
vamos não sabem o que é se ela só mãe
enlouquece sozinho só ela não precisa
definir o que sei não vou lhe dar um
exemplo bem breve você está comendo
almoçando é normal todo mundo mostra
isso é normal
pedia-lhe uma hora da tarde enquanto
você está comendo lavando louça enquanto
ela lavava louça conversa com o tamanho
que tem na cabeça dela e começa a
enlouquecer sozinha pode prestar atenção
o cara tá com medo ela lava louça fica
assim a paixão
tem quem lá né
olha o natal o menu só presta pra comer
na hora que eu terminado na vale chega
com um prato e pampa jumenta relava
[Aplausos]
vocês estão pensando que tem empregado e
rondava a lei quando eu morrer não
satisfeita com as coisas que ela fala
sozinha ela fica com raiva daquela
pessoa
ela vai tirar satisfação com você e você
não está sabendo de nada
aquela pessoa e ainda briga por uma
coisa que não tem nada a ver ela faz
aqui ó aí tô eu não vou comprar mar
embora não chega a visita não tem mais
nada já primeiro tudo no hotel filho
nobel cachorro é isso dói cara é porque
é dar de cara se deixar iludir como até
as cadeiras já a criança tem o mal
a criança nasce com um mal chamado saber
que tem
eu quando era menino 8 não conseguia
dormir pensando leite em que em cima da
metade não consegui achar meu irmão era
e virar por lata de leite e mel outro
meu deus do céu queria dormir a pregar
um quilo de leite no céu da boca assim ó
passar a noite retirando com a unha as
vezes que se eu limpava ouvido eu botar
na boca que ligou dipirona ruim um gol
de ouro
rio ave maria mas a criança gosta
enquanto na cabala no atleta não caro
enquanto não acabar um dia vamos ter uma
mãe chegou lá em casa
dilma chegou lá em casa com refrigerante
eu olhei pra ela pra mim era só um
refrigerante flutuando se dedicasse eu
fui acompanhando o refrigerante cara ea
criança com ela vai comigo ela começa a
encostar nela fica assim
ela botou refrigerante em cima da mesa
eu fiz a pergunta fatal de toda criança
olha parece assim estar a abrir agora
vai não mandar um pouquinho não a
criança quando ela não consegue o que
ela queria ela fala bem devagarzinho
talvez a mãe da mãe faziam sample que
não ser ruim não começa das opções é mãe
na xícara não mãe na tampa não mãe dela
minha mão não não deus não desistir não
é que a criança quando ela vai a fundo e
não consegue o que ela quis saber que
ela faz começa a jogar indireta mãe
sentou lá fora eu fiquei do lado dela só
assim o calor doido
acho que eu tenho é com sede
só que não é de água lixo e short é
preto de guarda quando o negócio que eu
ia ler hoje ela do vontade de tomar
cozinha com gás disse o botijão de gás
tap pode pegar não dava não d'água mas
também quando ela me dava eu devolvi do
mesmo jeitinho ruim e me dava
refrigerante retomá lá na porta de casa
fazem inveja por meio da rua
por mim brinca eu assim que as idéias é
a campeã não dava
nina bicho ruim para crianças é bicho
ruim você já vê uma criança quando ganha
25 centavos que ela faz
ela compra uma coisa não compra o guarda
não guarda passa o dia todo o dinheiro
na mão mostrando a cada ser humano que
passa o país aqui ó
ela canta tu nem tem e foi pai que
minguel que eu peguei no banco de pai
faz mágica cara você pode estar atrasado
para pegar um vôo e por japão portão
oportunidade de emprego ela consegue
parar
ele mostrava grande mágica que ela sabe
fazer você está correndo at eo que era
para ela faz aqui
[Aplausos]
só que acontece depois perde um pedido
tão ruim que ela é só existe uma pessoa
mais rica essa criança a mãe dessa
criança que ela aprendeu com a mãe que
título é uma mãe por aqui
aqui tem mãe que aqui começa o nome das
eu como
at lândia fala só de brincadeira hetland
mulher vontade não dá não compete dar
hoje eu tô sem orçamento não dá aqui
pela bahia me resultante land tudo bom
adelândia gillette hetland né hetland a
coisa boa né islândia não diverte
islândia
é lá que não tem ninguém que diga se eu
vou pra casa da minha avó como mandela
quer lei não é ético land raimunda
perdas e não né
rosimeire islândia só existem dois tipos
de mãe na terra
2 a mãe do ric a mãe do pobre foi a
diferença dela dúzia de um modo de criar
a criança ea mãe do rio faz quando foi
dela começa a correr e ela chama outra
pessoa pra pegar o menino porque ela não
quer que o filho dela cai e se machuca e
não a guerra d vendia arroz por favor
não pode né
pelo amor de deus não pode é que a mãe
do pobre faz quando o filho dela começa
a correr
ela chama outra pessoa pra assistir o
nome dela correr e cair pode afastar
essa o menino começa com ela faz paródia
em cartório
o capitão
a outra fala vai buscar a menina diz
preste atenção desta vai perder a
diversão na hora que o menino cai papel
não falei nem eu já não jogam
ela deixa ele cair
[Aplausos]
o tratamento é diferente que você pode
prestar atenção que o menino rico ele
cai no chão a mãe já vai correr no meu
deus de ar diferente onde estão os bons
modos sérgio macacos me mordam de hoje
eu estou linda né
parece filme o menino do papa quando ele
cai pode prestar atenção se ele caiu a
um quilômetro da mãe é um quilômetro que
ela vem xingando o menino o menino cai
para prestar atenção na doença que os a
desgraça já caiu o anderson mas minha
nossa
só vai mal o choro das crianças
diferente
o choro é muito diferente o menino rico
quando ele bate a cabeça no chão que ele
chora é lindo cara não é gosto vai
esquentar depois brasil tá lindo rico
caetano a voltar a gravar em pt botar no
spotify é lindo carla é gostoso menino
pobre bateu a cabeça no chão ninguém
sabe se uma criança chorando é o samu
chegando a atender a criança e já que
ele caia em parra escarro vão abrir no
popular do porto aqui ó
não dá
mágica
e chora de cobra tudo igual chora uma
criança sites e muitas casas é o meu não
meu nome eu tem catarro nessa e não
deixa no chão na mil megatts landu que o
menino vai eu sei não viu a irlanda
agora uma coisa que eu acho interessante
o menino rico que eu gosto
são dois pontos bom com 2.17 12 pontos
um bom e ruim que foi rastreada renan do
google mas é verdade eu tenho uma coisa
que eu não gosto nem do hit land aqui o
menino rico às vezes é eu quando era
criança não tinha muita condição das
coisas então quando eu vejo negando
comida rafiq onde já não quer dar um
danone e kerry não tomando nem eu nem
ligo de sair eu como até o plástico esse
negócio semelhante às vezes
agora uma coisa que eu gosto nem do rick
pode prestar atenção no mundo rico é
direto
ele cai ele chora atenção ele cai chora
a sinalizar que caiu ea mãe vem pegar
pra cuidar do menino o mundo rico é
direto e licá ele chora o do povo não o
menino quando ele cai parece que ele
fica sem entender o que aconteceu
o show estava em pé na estante de lei né
pode prestar atenção e ele fica assim é
todo ele pega nem pega time com nove
aí dá um sorriso que ninguém sabe se
está sorrindo está chorando em casa dá
pra daqui eu vou brincar mas não eu
na época seu pai não está cansado
aí aquele chora né
não leva um tempo
leva um tempo para entender o que
aconteceu o bichinho eivando
voltar de cágado apoio do mtur hetland
quando não mãe sai para trabalhar na
casa do pobre em geral quando a mãe
saiba trabalhar cada filho tem uma
função em casa
é tipo uma missão que a mãe dá pra cada
um essa essa tarefa é desempenhado pela
idade
quanto mais velho ele foi o grau de
responsabilidade da tarefa maior se vai
lavar
você vai julgar você vai guardar vai
aprendendo o que tipo empresa que a mãe
muda ela sair com a casa suja volta à
casa talento é assim que ela faz
só que tem uma tarefa mais importante de
todas chamado encher as garrafas de água
na geladeira só ficar pra mim essa
desgraça
eu tenho raiva de sair porque que essa
tarefa é fácil então jeito não dá
atenção para ela não é como o cara que
vai à casa de jane o cara que barra a
casa ele sabe que a casa tem um tamanho
então tem um tempo ele começar e
terminar o cara que enxerga garrafa não
ele fica ali sem fazer nada ou cada um
vá renda foi anunciado fazendo um
negócio muito baixo das garrafas de
carreta o show estados e revisá lo
a gente briga mãe me bate me faz isso
faz aquilo mas antes ela a visão há
cinco leis e mamãe me avisado a mãe de
filme não só o meu filho estes garrafas
para que tenhamos água potável para
beber haitianos weitz não olhava pra mim
ela falasse unidos
quantas garrafas de 604 ela quatro
garrafas
mas até para ter o pescoço quando chegar
[Música]
onde estou saindo para trabalhar agora e
não vou te falar mais nada ela saia já
me dava aquele gelo tão grande que eu ia
fazer logo só que meus amigos quando ele
via que minha mãe saía para trabalhar
eles ainda me chama porque tinha medo da
minha mãe minha mãe da casa em que
morava bola que alencar foi na bola eu
também que deseja a morte da minha mãe
sem internação
eles tinham medo da minha mãe então
quando a mãe saía oxi todo mundo no meu
portão e aí eu fui encher as garrafas
mãe saiu ele estava no portão de pé isso
quando eu abrir parecia a visão do
inferno por menino feia gerindo a lei
para ter figura não tinha preguiça não
elimine para os peões permita os olhos
da minha cidade ea nossa senhora era só
coisa feia o nome dormir já era feita
aos apelido catraca assenta vanda se era
só pela femme nossa assim eu não sei eu
juro que não sabia como lidar com aquele
mineiro tudo torto mas quer o braço de
uma operadora tudo e todo o grupo de
amigos é ter um líder e ver o líder
falar comigo eu levei todo torto assim
eu para jogar
isboa jogar o que eles tubeless seja
brincado bete tem outros nomes pelo
brasil paulo na lata tacutacu ball longo
de coisa pra quem não conhece eu vou
explicar a dor lata de óleo
só eu o tempo hetland só eu aqui um aqui
outro ali na frente da lata evento na
frente da lata um cara com um bastão né
aqui uma ripa que a gente achou quebrou
em 2001 tacada aqui atrás da lata o cara
com a bola para derrubar lata do outro e
quem está com a reebok é bater e eu era
o cara da bola
eu era um menino que eu tinha uma mira
meu era impressionante não errava uma eu
era o neymar dubet era proparoxítona eu
não era top e eu cheguei eu chegava com
a marra daquele menino mesmo goleiro
está ligado a cara quando desce do
ônibus com os condicionamentos assim
chegar naqueles naipe não só que eu
cheguei tinha me indiferente loire
bonita que já não é amigo meu e sei os
pés e rosa
eu digo não é amigo meu mesmo os pés -
amiga cinza e não tinha monage no mundo
que da taça espera aquele menino
avé maria husm com os pés em cinza
sandália do senninha
ele bate no chão piscava de gueto
transforma em outra forma tudo bem achei
bonito é o cara queria assistir só que
ele pegou um taco
ele pegou um taco já comecei a me chamar
simplesmente desafiando ele pegou o time
encarou enche meu coração de ódio rancor
digo vou mostrar pra esse mongolóide
como é que joga aqui que isso aqui é a
minha área
peguei a bola botar força que eu tinha
hetland o é
eu joguei esta bola ao menos 350
quilômetros para haiti
eu digo pega galeria pega meus amigos às
vezes deus deixem se achar melhor
deus deixa a gente pensar que a gente é
o maior
quando a gente chega lá em cima e ele
mostra que tem uma alegria melhor que a
gente
eu joguei essa bola não habilidade uma
precisão uma potência
esse menino rebateu com uma ignorância
tão grande que a terra parece que ficou
em câmera lenta para mim cara eu juro
pra você jogar à bola e fez aqui ó
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu olhei por meus amigos lá todo mundo
assim ó
[Aplausos]
at land olhava as folhas das árvores
está caindo e se inspira num
uma mulher de patinete na hora para
voado por ele rebateu paulo
o chinês adote um prego sair faísca
pareceu de volta com o futuro e os
cabelos sempre lá que fla cara lindo
deixo tudo em câmera lenta tinham vem
passando na hora está na velocidade dele
mesmo ele vai dizer que está na bola
passou por mim mesmo disse só daí é mim
eu eu fui pegar ó eu sentia na ponta do
dedo
só que ela foi sumindo relata smile e
ela sumindo sumindo sumindo quando ela
sumiu eu olhei para a esquina mamãe
voltando para casa já eu falei a garrafa
quando olhei para trás cada um menino
flap cabe a ripa eu tirei meu chinelo
para brincar e continuarei fazendo
chinela de anne hathaway estava sozinho
abandonado sem amigo tinha enchido uma
garrafa de água
com 10 anos de idade foi a primeira vez
que eu conversei com jesus que jura que
nem olhei para cima e se assim jesus
jesus alegado que o pai e meu pai também
né
me ajuda aí cara irlanda na hora
na hora eu olhei pro lado da mãe parou a
moto começou a conversar com a amiga
dela chegou jesus briga do cargo
jesus tu é jesus mesmo jesus bem
aventurada as crianças de jesus eo
garrafas caíram esquerda 10 mil cairão à
direita
não vai acontecer nada foi bem
devagarzinho estou aqui pra mim por
favor foi bem devagarzinho pelas paredes
que só não passando romã para me ver
aí eu passei por trás da moto quando eu
passei por trás da minha mãe amiga dela
me ver onde isto fica na tua tratar da
minha mãe assim
[Música]
baixem no portão elas conversamos
bastante no portão portanto houve um
ótimo os 15 anos da minha mãe e
valdenice eu puxei um sentimento dele
com a grita o nome da minha mãe de um eu
puxei volta é o daquele tempo pode
passar dos 10 segundos senti uma mão no
meu ombro pode tomar seja jesus eu vou
perder essa oportunidade de olhar para
jesus nem quando eu olhei pra cá as
unhas pintadas de 29º 2011 e olhei para
cima mãe bateu aquele gelo e michelin é
de olho eu levantei de passar confiança
entre osaka que passei o portão foi
fechando quando eu fui fechando o portão
na hora que eu ia célula quando eu
entrar na certa dúvida um gelo tão
grande porque o ruim pra criança não
apanhar
o ruim a criança saber que ela vai
apanhar daqui a pouco ela começa a
pensar coisa quem é o filho dele já deu
uma palmada normal de leve e leve
a mãe também bate de leve tirei raio x o
dia desses minha coluna torta de leve
colar mas é só
só de leve por de um palmo e meio deste
ano onde às vezes é bom ganhar não para
quem está batendo para quem a campanha
mesmo estilo média a surra é o pagamento
de uma dívida
o pagamento de uma dívida
chama a atenção que quando o exemplo de
alguma forma na tua filha em 30 segundo
um minuto ela está brincando e sorrindo
sobre o pagamento de uma dívida quando
você quebra um prato se devem na sua mãe
você leva sua ela não lhe deve mais nada
é d
por isso ela brinca sorrindo agora tem
uma grande diferença do choro antes de
apanhar e depois que apanha o dia antes
de apanhar é uma atuação que não tem
tarcísio meira no mundo pode prestar
atenção a mãe entrou dentro de casa
quando olhou para as garrafas de whisky
é isso aí amanhã o hífen camargo
eu corri por canto ea mãe quando ela
chega no cantagalo e bate no canto não
atrás por meio da sala
meu amigo nesse caminho ela me puxou na
hora lá para pegar o paypass nem doeu e
só saiam foi embora
só de boicote lan deu foi nada pra mim
falar padinha já bateu ensino a pegou
pelo braço assim ou você vai aprender já
mãe batia tão forte em cima do que eu
chorava em cima mas tudo bem eu mãe me
bateu 11 eo menino pobre quando ele
termina de chorar parece que tá ligando
a moto não é que tenho mãe me bateu e
subir em cima de levar até no piauí com
120 min
a criança diz ter vergonha eu era sem
vergonha muito era burro era criança eu
dizia assim mãe
amanhã eu fui para a escola amanhã a
moça ontem onde não eu também vou trocar
vá dando islândia onde a mãe pegou
batendo com ele no rio não foi pai não
tinha nada para fazer no time
entretenimento um danoninho crime crack
um videogame que nada a criança nada de
uma menina danada menina não a menina
até aos 13 anos ela ela descobre que o
menino gosta dela na escola pega ódio
nojo raiva
o menino com 3 ele vai me já lhe
roubasse a eles a vontade versão
aquilani eu não é besta
ele mede os amigo até cinco centímetros
ou ea minha que tem 61
[Música]
só que a criança é diferente ela é
inocente ela não é como o adulto adulta
esperto o adulto é muito esperto e um
adulto assistindo a pornografia
ele é esperto ele assiste mas ele sabe
que alguém pode chegar a qualquer
momento
[Música]
hum
i a criança não se havia uma criança
assistindo o vídeo por minuto uma
criança fica assim ó
pega no cursinho aqui ó de vez em quando
ele está temperada razão
é bom é bom ter em sazón e tem twitter
o pai quando pego no flagra ainda nem
tem fé e não presta atenção e não vê
quem entrar só que o pai é bom porque o
pai ajuda do pai pega o menino o fábio
ajuda ele ver o bichinho sobre ele já
passou por atlético está acabando o
poeta deixo vou beber uma água ali em a
yao ming espanta né no canal aumenta o
volume de liga televisão a mãe não me
parece que é com a bomba de fumaça que
ela pega no flagra a traição ela fala
que é o que está fazendo o que eu pedi
que me espanta roleta sai no cubo
obrigado de chá de coca depois o menino
não dá é difícil
[Aplausos]
é normal mas é difícil decidir como
pegou foi estranho tarde boa e eu era
esperto e bota o dedo no botão de mudar
já no ponto em que não tinha nada pra
fazer
era meia noite após noite e dormido
liguei a televisão ontem na band sempre
ver é pequeno ponto aqui ó botafogo no
botão de mudar se fosse vc era melhor do
que onde a televisão estatal do cordel
lançou nunca pegaram confiança mútua e
eu de bom aqui na minha né tranquilo só
no corinthians
a razão é que não acho que minha mãe
brotou da cerâmica
eu só escutei que ela vazia de mãe que
pega o menino flagra não têm alegado
econômico é bem fininha vai engrossando
faz aqui é o que a igreja universal está
fazendo o que eu digo assistindo culto
não tá vendo assistindo tudo isso eu
digo não estou aprendendo livros que li
no cantinho e assim aprendendo o que é
vagabundo já que o quarto foi meu quarto
wanga queria quebrar as coisas a criança
quer quebrar as coisas mas não pode
estar na plena né
cheguei no quarto esta desgraça
importa que é meu é meu
peguei meu notebook meu o encontrou mas
me deu é meu bem meu fone de ouvido
ontem no meu ouvido
entrei no meu site www.chevrolet.com.br
era quando eu tinha assistido
eu sempre pesquiso filme pornô dos caras
que têm a rolar o melhor caminho para
não ficar mal e eu voltei lavanda são os
eua
anderson com um anão é de entre a idéia
o play só quando você chega o volume 1
né
eu tenho 50 e na televisão a gente
baixar um pouquinho com medo né mas não
aqui tô no fone eliminou 51 80
a bottero 80 e 90
olhando assim carga de 10 cm tentou
diego e isso era de madrugada cara eu
tinha ninguém acordado na terra aquele
silêncio caras não tem como eu te peguei
aquele silêncio da madrugada que você se
espanta quando instalou o seu turno o
cara vai beber água e marudá até o
silêncio e hodel play começou só não foi
só no fone tabu incomoda ninguém
de madrugada é que ninguém acordado
silêncio e no meu fui levando seu
tornozelo
a venda judicial fazer
[Música]
cara eu fui mexer na cama notebook foi
por um lado fone saiu do outro
e cuoco na cidade
não se notou implementar de maceió não
preocupa que meus irmãos e não estão
entendendo é sério é sério
eu fechei esse notebook numa violência
ele era o windows xp o windows 8 na hora
h ele continuou temos que fechou
desligou a merda uma raivinha uma rainha
mãe acorda qualquer coisa numa rave
[Aplausos]
ou finge que está dormindo um finge que
todo mundo faz hora eu deitei deus 15
segunda porta e eu sou assim
somente assim o im
eu dei só que ela mastiga para enganar
pensar assim
ela gritou e foi o fim jica da pressão
pra gente acorda quente fica assim
ela falou instinto escutou um barulho aí
eu me superei hoje eu digo a vocês que
eu olhei pra ela pensa que eu fiz a voz
cafezinho que marujo essa taxa o método
mais dormir e ela foi muito fácil na
minha mãe cada momento pela alma do nome
ao tua mãe a alma
o estudo foi na cozinha ontem onde foi
ela graças à deus e quero a alma porque
a mãe não escutei um barulho na pia
murray vem lá do céu chegar aqui e lavar
a louça em casa ser louca louca
ai ai
a criança é muito danado corria pra
carai criança adora correr se soltam a
criança ela faz amizade correndo saber
pode faltar uma criança bem aqui na
frente em 30 segundo ela roda concha
acústica volta com 98 mil pra cá sem
saber nem o nome pode prestar atenção
parece não sei como é que é ele está
parado passa um boi e vai junto
chega amanhã é meu amigo que eu tenho
arrependimento mas não dele
reconhece menino e só que existe um
fenômeno muito grande chamado faltou
perna
às vezes o menino corre ele corre demais
e o suspeito passa das pernas e você
corre com as pernas tentando acompanhar
o suspeito
às vezes ele tá de boa conversando com
um amigo seu do nada passa a menina
assim
e você não consegue parar ele não só
consegue olhar pra ele calcular onde ele
vai cair só eu dei uma corrida dessas
que eu estava de manhã minha aula
acabava 1141 dragon ball acaba meio dia
neste ano a google empresa de cara em
correr
eu corri como se não houvesse amanhã
eu corri como um puxão um turista lá no
final do pelourinho kadhafi tinha lá em
cima muito afeito a currier joá chegou
na frente de casa faltou aspecto ea
criança é [ __ ] que quando ela volta da
escola ela vem com a bolsa ea bolsa
o primeiro mortal de uma criança com a
bolsa tem que se esforçar me ao cadastro
ae é o primeiro portal dessa criança e
eu em tu tu tu tu tu quando faltou
aspecto é o paa na frente de casa em
outro lugar no mundo cá eu caí na frente
de casa quando eu olhei pra porta mãe
vindo chegou a me ajudar
aonde eu levo um tirano barro e mamãe
vindo
ela chegou ela parou na porta
parou na porta são três curtas tenho
medo como eu falo
quando chegar em casa não é certa
principalmente quando ela pega pelo
braço e fala sem mexer os lábios
às vezes o cara tá correndo aniversário
coisa boa e correndo aniversário
correndo de boa batida roubos referente
a gente fica olhando aquele golo bonito
né pois um empate o parabéns ele se
esconde o bolo veio provar deixa de bola
e rolar do papel domingo
é ruim e fica com raiva joga no chão a
mãe deixou pelo puxou pelo braço quando
chegar em casa mais acerto da olhou com
a amiga disse ruy saiu puxando ele
acabou minha vida
segunda coisa quando seu pai chegar você
vai ver a chegar você vai ver dar um
minuto ligar papai se o tal onde se
ouvem que ora já falou que o senhor não
nada na besteira assim quando ligar não
atende
bom te amo para se livrar da pena
a terceira coisa que tinha mais medo
como em fala uma frase é uma palavra
quando ela pára na porta conta pra gente
faz aqui ó passa me bater e mãe era tão
cínica que ela com cinto na mão
desenvolvo mundo está a ansa
eu dizia salto sim
eu confiava num batizei minha mãe de yu
ela perdia um cinto ela já tinha
colocado um chinelo e molde defesa grado
para baixo
eu digo não dá não mamãe danon eu tenho
que passar a comandar a passar a fazer o
que morava ali tinha que entrar no bar
passa eu tomar distância não sou besta
ocorrer se o replay e agora pela
primeira vez em salvador
islam lojas é a mesma cena
só que agora em super super câmera lenta
com os detalhes que vocês não poderão
ver a olho nu
eu olhava pra minha mãe e
chegar de casa comemorava olhar para
tentar meu pai olha pra trás
eu olhei um cinto na mão
irmã mãe da amiga uma mulher igual mega
sorte mega sorte dá um golpe então fazer
uma pose nem retira mãe às vezes ela
deixar eu passar eu passava vivo é essa
fazer sim no meu deus
o dia era livre
mamãe mamãe era demais
aqui o bateu muito apanhou muito
ae
tem que ser assim mesmo eu paguei eu vou
rir até morrer agora tem gente que assim
a 70 conta cadeira é até cabelo rio ea
ferrovia tem que rever coisas boas o rio
ai ai eu era pequeno tinha rabo de
inglês
eu pensava que as pessoas me xingando e
as pessoas me xingando só falava hari
usuário a tomar aquela vagabunda
a raiva inglês ninguém sabe tyler disse
que sabem ler mas não sabe quem foi que
nunca fecha em 31 à noite um suspeito
não é o inglês martin do mundo amanhã
frente ao everton em barueri é muito boa
para esse jeito e todo mundo sabe o
refrão a gente só sabe o refrão da
música ver o mar e que no domingo é
verdadeiro
o novo nós sabe né
agora do bairro novo nome era esse e não
sabe
muito obrigada salvador
a cápsula que deus abençoe vocês - você
faz suas casas estão no rio salvador
vou fazer aquela foto bem bonito eu
gostava agora o corinthians é um dos 36
já todo mundo levanta a mão aí fala tá
puto é só você e já balançou muito
obrigado tamo junto
que deus abençoe vocês não jogou
[Aplausos]